let me start with congrats on Midnight
Madness and winning uh which is crazy uh
like I mean when you think about when
where the film started and everything
about this it's crazy to win that
category we agree and we're thrilled and
we're thrilled so before I jump I have a
ton of questions but before I get into
uh the film I have to ask you an
individual question uh what do I need to
pay to see the Larry David documentary
ah a lot of
money yeah you may have to wait a few
years yes whenever it's available or or
I would love people to see it believe me
I'm not the one stopping people from
seeing oh oh I
know I am I've been one this whole time
Josh has decided he doesn't want the
movie to come I said wait until this
movie's out Larry so one of the things I
actually want to touch on is I respect
so much that a24 has has made a deal to
make it so you guys can promote this uh
can you sort of talk about the fact that
small company makes deal other companies
what the I mean you sort of said it
right there which is I think what
they're trying to like show with these
interim agreements is that of course
they're like an independent company
that's not affiliated with all the
struck companies that are negotiating
against us but furthermore they have to
sign a contract that meets all the
Union's wishes which it's like feels
like a trillion dollar tech company
would be able to do so it's been we just
feel very lucky to be here period for
all those reasons right yeah we're
surprised that that Paradigm of h24
isn't being applied to every other
Studio you know it was like that that
would be the end of the strike you know
and they are able to do it they're able
to be successful and be able to make
cool stuff and be able to sign these
contracts also so if they could do it
why can't everybody else do it yes right
completely uh and I have a question for
you what is the secret to Playing God oh
the secret to Playing God is finding
like the right register to deliver the
message because I think about it and I
think you seeing God up top in the
beginning of the movie Keys the audience
into the fact that he is like the
delivery system for the story like this
is an this must be an important
narrative if God is kind of relaying it
to you you know so I think that that
that's it and it's it's it makes sense
that he is in this movie and it pays off
in the end so oh 100% um and very Rocky
Horror you know yeah narrator you want a
fun narrator popping in there one of the
things about this film is that and I
wrote it's a musical it's a comedy it's
science fiction and it's
horror get it and and it's funny and
like and it has the sewer voice you know
like it has everything can you sort of
talk about the the blending of
everything together because it's very
hard to pull something like this off
yeah a funny story is when we were first
meeting with a24 about this eron and I
as a joke we're like we wanted to be the
hereditary of comedies and they were
like oh yeah like okay I do think you're
right it's got a lot of things going on
in it it's uh it's just good old
fashioned maximalism you know there's a
lot going on and I think people can
handle a lot audiences like you know
they don't need it to just be like one
thing um they can handle many things
coming at them the original review was
was like 40 minutes or something so but
it lent itself I mean it was touching on
so many interesting issues that it
almost was like naturally able to grow
into the story that it became which is
touching on all those different genres
and synthesizing them into a coherent
hole I also think because it started as
a Twan show that was like a half hour
that we would do in the basement of a
grocery store it was like a runaway
train because we were just like
compressing The Parent Trap and blowing
it out so I felt like that energy and
DNA was always there so even when it got
bigger it was like okay well now it can
push even more directions and it's
always felt weirdly organic also it
never felt we never felt with all these
crazy elements that we were contriving
or shoving things in or just getting it
in for shock value everything kind of
made sense in our internal logic they
have to go into the sewer right that's
check off's gun when you meet a sewer
boy in act one you know they're going to
go into the
SE um I cannot express to you how much I
enjoyed the sewer boys and how what the
as I everything about that us to
they were an honor to work with you know
we auditioned them we auditioned a lot
of people their sort of discoveries just
we're happy for them I'm glad to give my
little guys a break you know and they it
wasn't tokenism it was absolutely not
Ste boys playing Ste boys is not token
it was representation we read a lot of
actors for it they didn't bring
authenticity backpack and
Whisper uh so I love talking about the
editing process because it's where it
all comes together so I'm curious um how
did the film possibly change in the
editing room in ways you didn't expect
going in well first of all because we
had a 20day schedule uh even though we
improvised a lot and we were very very
loose within that 20-day schedule we did
not have I purposely did not have a lot
of extra coverage or extra footage I
mean I didn't want that I wanted the
movie to be the movie and so the movie
was the movie from almost the very
beginning then you go through an editing
process where you're getting notes you
know people have thoughts some things
you try out and experiment with I again
try to follow my instinct through that
entire process and feel the movie feel
what what's satisfying to me as an
audience member I'm watching it as an
audience member too and so those things
just kind of fell together properly
nothing was really planned in advance
it's like let's capture this Zeitgeist
of the moment and see what we have I do
I mean he's right there's like no
cutcenes because we didn't have time to
shoot any
other but also it was so fun to then
when we finally saw it back to see that
you and Al LaVine the editor did all
this cool like split screen mods stuff
there's a lot of like fun poppy things
that happen in the edit that I think
like serve the movie that I never
pictured the footage of New York City I
really love all which that that stuff
was all I I thought about those kind of
things beforehand because I thought that
would be fun I was just thinking what
would be fun in this movie what would
keep you engaged and all these kind of
different elements are are those things
and keeping the blemishes like there's a
moment where I break there's a moment
where someone doesn't hit a mark and the
camera has to pull over to them there's
just like a lot of that little stuff too
that's fun I did enjoy the bloopers uh
during the credits and I'm just curious
when you're doing something like that do
you have to get everyone's permission or
to like to show it or is it sort of just
like n you shot it God don't tell
Nathan make us P it I think you do need
per possibly but um permission is
something I'm I'm used to
ignoring so one of the things who going
to be a bunch of people that are going
to soon to be fans of the movie what do
you think would surprise them to learn
about the actual making of the film The
20 days is pretty wild that it was shot
in 20 days what else surpris we sing a
lot of it live we sang A lot of it live
and a lot of it sort of like two takes
because there was no more time also that
it was maybe this isn't surprising but
it was just like such a fun joyful
summer camp feeling I know we're being a
little like naughty and edgy but like
The Vibes were always just everybody was
doing it from a place of silliness and
joy so it was like a very fun um set
yeah it was I think when you see the
movie you see the experience that we had
making it you feel the the enthusiasm
the craziness the the excitement of what
we were doing and I wanted that movie to
feel the way we felt we were shooting
and the way they felt when they were
doing the play in the first place yeah
and for for as offensive as the movie is
I mean the experience of it was so
wholesome it was just all showing up and
being great you know showing up on time
and being consider let put on a show but
with a vagina yeah yeah
yeah uh for the two of you I am very
curious what was it like finding out
that he was interested to direct because
it it I mean it's a big deal to get him
on the project absolutely we were it was
shocking yeah and we were so scared
about the director and and we're just
like cuz it's such a it's such an
interesting specific project and we were
really really terrified and then we
heard Larry Charles we're like oh my God
we were thrilled yeah and then we and
then the second we all met it was just
felt very same brain where we were like
oh Larry fully understands the vision
and Larry gets the process and was so
like welcoming and inclusive of us as
collaborators so just like I don't know
it was a joy from moment one I was
thrilled too I was I was incredibly
thrilled that this is all going to come
together it was exciting it was an
exciting fun experience really one of a
kind I appreciate a24 for making this
because anything that pushes boundaries
thumbs up on that note have a
fantastic day thank
you